Oh scratching the butt hey I'm Jordan
and my sister Aviva is visiting from out
of town there is nobody on the planet
who loves monkeys more than my sister my
sister even talked about a monkey in her
wedding speech your unconditional
support is like no other
I mean you even let me think there could
be a monkey mother at her pre-school
graduation she said that what she wants
to be when she grows up
is a mother monkey and when she found
out she couldn't be one she cried for
days I officiated my sister's wedding
and I really wanted to surprise her with
a monkey as the ring bearer but we
weren't able to work it out there so now
I'm gonna surprise her with a monkey
today it's gonna destroy her what are
you here to do today Jordan and I are
going to transform into each other
through makeup he's my little brother so
it'll be interesting the only thing we
really look alike in is that we both
have brown eyes I think it's gonna be
funny everything's gonna be awkward for
sure but if she nails it then I'm gonna
be in all of the makeup artists oh my
goodness hi Dexter
I want my news I'm so excited oh my
goodness hi hi oh hello oh hello this is
so awesome I'm so excited I'm sorry I'm
freaking out I love monkeys and I never
get to be around them when my husband I
got married we had two little monkeys on
top of our cake always been things that
I've wanted to do a spend time with them
Jordan had me convinced I was here for
some other reason
[Music]
there it goes hey you sneezed on me well
I was super surprised I didn't think
Jordan could surprise me but he did in
fact I'm just so excited to be around
among for you so this experience has
been amazing for me I I can't say enough
I'm just I can't stop looking at this
monkey this expression when he did that
was amazing
studied awesome he's full of energy is
awesome I'm jealous ed I don't get to
keep him
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]